you
you
chapter one
this session is being recorded so that
people can access this later from the
Cornell Barry website and now we'll move
into the meat of our program and this is
where I want to make another explanation
I have to apologize to dr. Mike Ellis
who is our guest from The Ohio State
University he is a professor and
extension state specialist in
plant pathology of diseases of fruit
crops and he agreed to do this months
ago and for some reason and next to his
topic I wrote down fruit rots and an
excuse me root rot instead of fruit rats
but he will be talking about fruit rots
today which according to the feedback
that we got is actually a really good
thing as that is a problem for most of
you now at this point I'm going to turn
it over to dr. Ellis and Mike you can
turn your microphone on and
I'm gonna let you take it from here I'll
turn mine off okay can can you hear me
yes we can hear you beautifully okay
well I've hello everybody this is quite
an experience being on this webinar it's
the first one I've ever done and I'm
glad it's working out I know Laura's
worked real hard on it my presentation
I've been working on it i hope i keep it
right at about 30 minutes so i'm going
to have to get going i hope i don't go
too fast but there's a lot of things i'd
like to share with you i would like to
emphasize i see quite a few people on
here that are professionals educators
and the talks really designed primarily
for growers but hopefully you'll find it
interesting again that's Mike Ellis I'm
muha State University I've been here
about 30 years so I've been working with
strawberry fruit rots for quite some
time how do I start the powerpoint Mike
just you can yeah I just hit the little
arrow at the bottom
and we can okay I've got it oh you want
to get rid of there we go okay all right
let's hope we don't have any more
technical difficulties it anyways the
pleasure to be here let me get going
first of all when I talk about any type
of the disease management I try to
emphasize the importance of developing
integrated management programs for
diseases of whatever you're working with
and I'm going to be talking about
strawberry fruit rots here today for me
the major components of an integrated
program or disease resistance cultural
practices biological control if you have
it minimal fungicide use whenever I talk
about fungicide use I like to work use
the word minimal and the knowledge of
disease biology for me this knowledge of
disease biology something that a lot of
people really overlooked and I want to
take the first part of my presentation
today to try to emphasize the importance
of understanding diseases or at least
having a basic understanding of them in
order to be able to control them
effectively the knowledge is critical to
the development of disease management
strategies and I always say the star
growers I say how can you effectively
manage a plant disease or actually
anything without some knowledge about it
you know the basic knowledge on ecology
or epidemiology the more you know about
what you're trying to control the better
off you're going to be in terms of
controlling it and one thing I try to
emphasize wherever I speak to growers is
they need to find out what resources are
available that have this information
know most states have excellent
information I know throughout the
Northeast there is in the Midwest we
have a series of publications this is
the Midwest small fruit pest management
handbook it contains all the information
I'm going to be presenting on fruit rots
here today we also have the Midwest
strawberry production guide it has all
this information in and I'm not trying
to sell these I'm just trying to
emphasize the importance of growers
knowing what resources are out there and
in getting them and looking at them
learning from them so let's talk a
little bit about the epidemiology and
control of strawberry fruit rots and
here
I'm going to try to go through the three
major fruit rots and emphasize some
things that we've learned that help us
understand them better and hopefully
control them better our three major
fruit rots are botrytis leather rot and
anthracnose i'll start with botrytis
fruit rot or grey mould this is a
typical symptom on a ripe fruit it looks
like a dead mouse anybody that's raised
raspberries or strawberries is familiar
with botrytis it's probably the most
common fruit rot disease and is probably
responsible for most of the fungicides
worldwide that are applied to
strawberries again this is symptoms in
the field now when I first started about
30 years ago growers in the Midwest and
the east used to spray fungicides for
botrytis to control it from early spring
free bloom through harvest this could
result in four to six applications of
fungicide or more and this is what was
perceived was the need in order to
control this disease I got to remember
where to click here I just want to go
over some studies that were conducted
you know many years ago actually but
they've really let us develop a good
understanding of this disease and I
think it really allows us to control it
better first of all we used to think
that botrytis was everywhere it came in
from outside the planning and it was
just ambiguous everywhere actually we've
learned that the fungus actually forms
latent infections during late summer and
fall in apparently healthy leaves you
could have a planning out there looks
absolutely beautiful perfectly healthy
but it can be infected with botrytis
some of the leaves in this planning
right here are infected and if you clear
them you can actually see the mycelium
of botrytis within the leaves well you
go into the fall the plants go dormant
you cover up with spring and obviously
this is a perennial matted row but
underneath that straw that fungus the
leaves died the fungus become
saprophytic active and if you go out
there in the spring and dig out some of
the leaf litter this is a student of
mine that was actually studying
sporulation several years ago
and you put it you get down there and
look you can actually see botrytis poor
you Layton on the surface I don't know
how to I forgot how to use the mouse on
this thing the right yeah I've got it
right here there you can actually see
the fungus exploring Layton this is just
a close up of some additional litter try
to get the handle on the mouse here
anyway the point we're trying to make is
virtually 99% of all the inoculum that
comes from botrytis and you're in your
planning comes out of that row in the
litter early in the spring but what's
most important that we've learned is the
fact that virtually all probably ninety
percent or more of the infections that
occur from botrytis occurred during
bloom now this is an extremely important
point and it was really emphasizes the
importance of having some knowledge and
this is a flower the fungus colonizes
old flower parts senescence parts it
actually moves down into the receptacle
of the fruit where it develops a latent
infection it sits there because the
tissue on green fruit is not susceptible
to rot this is from some work that we
were doing on infection of the fruit and
actually this center of berry right here
has a latent infection in it so it sits
there you're looking at your field you
got green food everything looks great
and then as the fruit starts to mature
the fungus the physiology changes the
fungus becomes active and it causes a
rotten you can see here that the rod
really developed around the calyx into
the of the fruit or the flower and this
is when the symptoms are but try to show
up and this is what you see in the field
in the past people would see this they
would start spraying obviously if the
infection occurred during bloom any
sprays that you're putting on out here
now or a way
the money and time and the ferry hit
efficient use of fungicide at any rate
so this I hope this is probably about
the best definition of understanding the
disease and how it's helped us to
control it so we know for control of
botrytis applications of fungicide
during bloom are absolutely critical and
actually as far as the success story i
would say in ohio now instead of four to
six applications per year for botrytis
growers just targeting applications
during bloom and matter grill systems
probably spray twice maybe at the most
three times so we're looking at least a
fifty percent reduction in fungicide use
now anthracnose fruit rot a strawberry
and threat knows is an extremely
devastating disease and it's it's very
interesting and difficult to work with
this is the septum on fruit this is on a
plastic culture berry Chandler and with
several lesions on it these lesions are
actually covered with spore masses this
book funguses splash disperse when a
raindrop hits that lesion it just blows
spores all over surrounding fruit so it
can spread very rapidly in the field in
the past anthracnose was thought of a
warm weather or southern disease of
strawberry was not considered a problem
in northern production areas when I
first got here again 30 years ago they
never heard of anthracnose anthracnose
fruit rot caused by Cola tatra cream was
epidemic for the first time in Ohio in
1991 economic damage was not observed
prior to this date as far as I know
anthracnose again it likes hot wet
weather in 1991 we had 80 degree
temperatures 85 to 90 throughout the
Midwest and Northeast from the beginning
of bloom through harvest with plenty of
rain therefore this anthracnose epidemic
developed and it occurred across the
entire Midwest and Northeast this is a
planning a late grow strawberries that
that's in its second year of production
this is on a farm near Worcester where
I've done a lot of research and this is
about two acres out of 10 acres and
actually this is the second year the
first year of production it was
beautiful production no fruit rots this
year is 1991 the hot year grower called
me up and said hey we got a problem
we're seeing spots on the fruit I went
out and looked and within a week
eighty-five percent of the fruit and
that two acre planning looked like this
is infected with in threat knows
extremely devastating this was one of
the most devastating losses that I've
really ever experienced in a strawberry
planning at any rate anthracnose once it
shows up it is an absolute nightmare our
big question was where it come from this
grower that where this late glow
planning was been growing strawberries
for over 40 years and this was the first
time we'd ever seen it so our big
questions are where did it come from and
how was it introduced into the planning
we know that anthracnose is introduced
into the field on infected transplants
some beautiful work by Mark Gleeson at
Ohio State and his students this belief
right here is a perfectly normal healthy
leaf but when you look at it
microscopically this is a piece of
mycelium of Cola toxic evacuate them
actually growing on the surface of this
healthy leaf and producing a Canadian
these canadia are infective here's
another shot of some mycelium on the
surface of the leaf and Canadian so this
fungus can move around very very
effective effectively on healthy-looking
nursery stock so you don't know if you
have it there's no indexing program for
it so we know that it moves around and
it's just kind of a pig in the poke if
you're lucky you don't have you got
clean plants and if you're unlucky you
have the potential for anthracnose
epidemic in your vet in your in your
planning so and we don't know if you
don't know if you have it till it shows
up so what I've been tellin growers and
trying to work with them is in growing
seasons where you experience hot weather
through bloom and harvest hot wet
weather you should consider having
fungicides in your program for
anthracnose control in relation to
plastic culture which is growing in
popularity rapidly in Ohio and in many
areas the use of a fungicide a good
fungicide program for control of
anthracnose is mandatory it's just the
nature of this production system and
track nose is a potential threat all the
time and you need to have a good
fungicide program for anthracnose
control and plastic culture yeah Mike
could I do it for a second did you did
you see you at question from wind Smith
about everbearing and whether or not you
can control well because of the
continuous bloom and and maybe you don't
want to answer any questions until at
the end of your presentation i don't
know i think i think i better get
through this and answer them at the end
but that that is an excellent question
and I try to talk to that primarily in
my hand out but let me go on through
okay sounds great but people keep typing
your questions as they come to you and
we can go back through of them at the
end of the presentation that that that
is an absolutely excellent question the
difference between perennial matted row
and plastic culture is you know it's a
whole different world most of everything
we've worked with and the bulk of our
production is perennial matted row but
that is a good point in terms of timing
fungicides but I'll try to talk to that
later I got this that pretty well
hopefully do about 30 bit itself so I've
tried to have a hang with that and I
think what about 15 minutes at the end
anyway I'd like to talk a little bit
about leather route right now leather
rod is a very serious problem in Ohio
and in some states it's worse than other
states it's usually associated with
heavier soils and poor drained soils but
any rate this is a typical symptom
leather rots particular trial
problematic in that what infected food
haven't
taste and smell but the taste is just
horrible and oftentimes people will see
this white area and think it's just
under ripe cut it off and go ahead and
put the strawberries on the shortcake
and go ahead and eat it and it tastes
terrible so they know where they got the
berries and they're a little bit upset
about it also we found that the one or
two birds in a gallon of infect or and
gallon of fruit will throw the flavor
off of jams so let it rot is uh it's
kind of the producers nightmare if you
got even one percent of it you're
planning
Mike up we lost wispy you abused your
audio just for a second so I don't know
what happened but just maybe if you want
to repeat if you said anything important
we better hear it again well I I don't I
don't know what cut out I hope
everything is important in any way at
this point I'm just going to keep going
i was talking about leather rot I'll
back up a little bit on that but the
leather rot is a kind of a nightmares
producer and the fact that it produces a
very bad taste and sometimes the fruit
doesn't really look like it's rotted it
just don't maybe under right and people
will use those and it really results in
some serious customer relations when
people get bad taste and berries at any
rate when we look at the disease this is
an effective fruit in the field this is
in time this infected fruit actually dry
down and call and develop into these
things we call mummies it's actually a
combination of the pathogen and the host
it's a hard dry but inside of that thing
is a thick-walled resting olas poor of
phytophthora cacked orem and this old
sport can stay in the soil for 30 years
and i'll just bet you anyplace where
there's been strawberry production these
old spores are present in the grounds
but the key thing about this old spores
it's just going to sit there until you
have saturated soil so the key to this
disease is saturated soil water water
saturated soil once you get that for
relatively short period of time they
germinate and form sporangia and these
sporangia then develop what's called ZOL
spores little by flageolet spores
similar to a sperm cell that can
actually swim in the water in the soil
and in puddles and therefore the key to
controlling leather rot is drainage
anytime I see standing water in a
strawberry field I cringe here's a
fruit was fight off they're actually
sporulating on it you can bet that that
water is just full of zone spores so
every time a raindrop hits in there just
splashes the healthy fruit and it's off
and running and you've got an epidemic
on your hands so understanding the fact
that saturated soil is important for
this disease should help us to control
it and for me the the major control for
leather rot our cultural practices
primarily site selection good soil
drainage and use of mulch now I just run
over those things that's kind of like
the first half of the talk I just tried
to show you some instances where we're
understanding or that demonstrate that
when we understand more about the
diseases the better equipped we're going
to be to control them and I think
botrytis is probably the the real
classic example we've really made
strides in in understanding the disease
and controlling it better but moving on
into an integrated management program
again I try to emphasize the importance
of disease biology or a knowledge of it
disease resistance cultural practices
biocontrol minimal fungicide use disease
resistance you know it's a no-brainer
it's the first line of defense if you
got resistance you use it in my
extension programming in Ohio I say
leave spot diseases you better be
looking at resistance for those are you
going to be doing a lot of extra
spraying and in the past at least we've
had some excellent varieties with good
leaf spot resistance unfortunately we do
not have good resistance to the fruit
rots there is some potential for
resistance and then threat knows and
some of the plastic culture or annual
varieties but it's really not out there
yet so if we don't have any resistance
we're completely dependent upon
fungicide use or cultural practices for
the control so fungicides are very very
important for controlling fruit rots on
strawberries fortunately we have an
excellent arsenal fungicides for
controlling all the major fruit rot
diseases botrytis leather rot and
anthracnose
I could give you a whole day workshop on
the use of fungicides I do have a
handout that's going to be available to
print off the lower should be able to
get it to you at any rate I want to go
through and mention a few things but
this is going to be pretty brief for
fungicides for botrytis we just about
ten years ago we started losing
fungicides and I was concerned we
weren't going to have any but we have an
excellent arsenal fungicides for control
of botrytis and all of these these would
be the the Cadillac fungicides over on
this side on all of them were excellent
tops and i would probably put at the
bottom of the list because it's been
around so long there's probably
resistance but switch elevate pristine
and Scala wonderful materials from
botrytis i like to use them combined
with Captain early in the season the
combination may help with some fungicide
resistance prevention also using captain
with it early may help prevent some of
the build-up of anthracnose in the
planning on those apparently healthy
look and leaves and throughout those
fruit front let me mention one other
thing all of these fungicides are in
different classes of chemistry so they
can all be alternated with each other in
resistance management schemes France
Rock knows in the past we had captain
and thigh Ram not really very effective
captain's not bad you got to spread off
a lot of it if you've got a problem with
anthracnose fairly recently the strobel
urine fungicides abound trying to use my
pointer bound cabrio and pristine we're
introduced these are really cadillacs
for anthracnose and really gave us some
effective tools for controlling it
switch it's a fantastic material for
botrytis but it also does a good job
against anthracnose so fortunately we do
have some good fungicides to help us in
control of anthrax knows leather rot we
actually have quite a few in the past
captain and thigh Ram again were the
only things that were available not very
effective but riddim ins
Mills been around a long time but it's
very effective for leather rot control
the phosphorous acid fungicides fostro
agri fast topaz pro fight and aliette
are very effective for leather out
control and the stroller urines again
remember these strobel urines these
things are excellent fungicides they
help us with strawberry disease
management as oxy strobe and abound
pirate cluster oven cabrio and pristine
pristine all of these are excellent for
leather rot as well um again I have some
suggested guidelines they should be you
should be able to print them out at the
end of this presentation if not contact
me and i'll be happy to get get them to
you but i've tried to outline everything
all my de best recommendations for using
fungicides for controlling strawberry
fruit rots yes Mike thank you so much
that was very good and I I just want to
let people know that when we move to the
very final portion of this program we
will be able to download your handout
which is very comprehensive so i will
point directly to that to folks and we
do have a couple of extra minutes so if
people would like to ask
dr. Ellis a question this is the
toughest of it would be a good time so
other than that one question from Gwyn
Smith about everbearing Disease Control
well they're probably thinking about it
we'll have another opportunity at the
end of the program so that you can do
that as well I just I wanted to check i
don't see scale listed in the new york
state guidelines for use in new york
state yet so i just wanted to mention
that for new york state growers
and there's a couple people typing right
now so maybe they know better they
probably do but while we're getting that
answer let me change this and we'll okay
okay Kathy heidenreich is answering that
and skala is listed in the team app so
it is labeled for strawberry gray mold
and Alan has a question I had I had a
couple of uh just other real quick
comments first of all in relation to
these strobel urines abound in cabrio
the best for anthracnose fruit rot a mic
we lost you for a second but and
oppression
um Mike we're losing your audio for some
reason and one last I've had some other
stuff but okay keep trying to hear me
now yes we can hear you know I don't
know why it wasn't you hear me yes yes
we can well actually had a couple other
points to make here okay pristine
pristine is an outstanding material did
you hear me yeah you can own a little
bit this might go ahead all right all
right Christine is an outstanding
material for controlling strawberry
fruit rots it's a combination a cabrio
or the struggle urine and boskie lube
which is a botrytis and a powdery mildew
material but it is the only one
fungicide that provides excellent
control of all three of the major fruit
rots botrytis anthracnose and leather
rot it's good for you spots good for
powdery mildew and it will give some
post-harvest control of botrytis I was
going to mention some things on cultural
practices but I guess I'll stop right
here all right we have one other
question from chautauqua county they're
talking about at what rate should the
chemical be applied and I think all of
that is in the guideline so you'll have
to check that for whatever stage
all of that all of that is in the
guidelines one thing I would like to
emphasize is especially when we're in
plastic culture whenever i'm making a
spray for botrytis or anything i'd like
to include captain into the program
early I think it's going to help prevent
some of the build-up of anthracnose if
anthracnose is an issue so especially in
plastic culture I'd like to keep captain
in the in virtually about every spray up
until the point you have to worry about
visible residues on fruit once you start
getting fruit developed and you worry
about visible residues you have to back
off on the captain because you don't
want those visible residues and all
these other materials will not result in
visible residues all right great we have
one other question Mike from Alan and
he's wondering about bio controls for
these diseases ball controls you know I
I really wish that there were some
things out there that I could recommend
for ball controls but quite frankly
there are not and I'm not prepared to
recommend them in the west side they're
going to take care of the situation
under heavy disease pressure I know that
there are a few materials out there I've
tested them but I just haven't found
anything that i've incorporated into my
recommendation right great and astonish
lohman has a great comment about getting
pristine it was a challenge this year
for growers so buying ahead
is a good idea and then Kathy
heidenreich has put the link to the
label for some of this materials that
we're talking about so that would be
helpful thank you both for those
comments and thank you dr. Ellis for
your presentation I'm hoping you're
going to be still here because I
anticipate that we'll probably have some
more questions
now we're going to switch slightly to
dr. David Kaduri and let me just try to
bring up
this is the wrong one sorry it was a
practice one that we had
here we go sorry about that dr. Kaduri
let me try to get your share screen on
dr. ghadr e we're going to be looking at
his presentation right off of his
computer because he had a couple of
graphs that didn't come through so he
practiced this earlier and it worked
beautifully so let me see if we can find
that you know what I think I'm going to
bring up a brand-new share pod
david and then you can just go right to
your computer screen
and I'll let you turn your microphone
yeah there we go perfect
and David you could just click your
microphone on when you're ready
we do this great dr. Kaduri is a plant
pathologist with Cornell University I'm
working out of the agricultural
experiment station in Geneva and he has
done a lot of work with strawberry
powdery mildew and we're very pleased to
have him so David I'll just turn this
over to you
David if you want to toggle on your
speaker and mic if you could toggle off
yours
David try that toggle on toggle off a
couple times perhaps maybe it'll do it
for you
yeah I'm not hearing you i don't know if
anybody else can hear you
okay yeah maybe come down and toggle it
on before you fill up your there you go
we're watching what you're doing perfect
how's that perfect thank you okay now
we're back on us that and now we do that
there you go great great all right now
can everyone hear me like that you guys
can put agree if you can hear him it
looks like they can hear you terrific
okay good well then off we go well good
afternoon everyone as you can see by the
the number of authors on the title slide
I'm the one that's talking today but
this is this is not really an individual
effort it represents about three years
of collaborative work between Cornell's
Department of Plant Pathology at Geneva
and some colleagues of ours in of all
places Norway's National Agricultural
Research Centre near oslo now I come to
strawberry powdery mildew from a
background of about 20 years of research
on a closely related disease powdery
mildew of grapevine but I find
intriguing about strawberry powdery
mildew other many parallels between
these two diseases so in the next few
minutes that I'd like to go over some
things we know and that we don't know
about this disease because we've only
generated new knowledge on the biology
and ecology of the pathogen and we've
also had to unfortunately unlearn some
long established facts regarding our
very powdery mildew so let's get started
on that well all living organisms are
are subject to classification by a group
of scientists who call themselves
taxonomy now taxonomist SAR the the
people who choose the names for these
pathogens there are a lot like tax
attorneys in that they they tend to
create confusion and then they profit by
it and the name of the moment that
they've applied to the strawberry
powdery mildew is put us for a Fanus but
you will find that in
in many other publications listed by
many other names it's it's all the same
pathogen there really is only one
powdery mildew on strawberry and it goes
by many names so just keep that in mind
it's all the same pathogen with respect
to powdery mildews in general I think
we've been loaned into a sense of
complacency about partnering uldouz in
general because for many years as as
Mike pointed out we've had a wealth of
very effective fungicides that limit the
amount of damage they can inflict
however pottery mildews as a group are
historically among the most troublesome
pathogens with respect to fungicide
resistance in fact complete failures of
entire classes of our best modern
fungicides have now been reported for a
number of different party mildews on
different crops and it's it's quite
possible that we may see a similar
pattern of resistance eventually in
strawberry so resistance management and
the minimal use of fungicides as they're
needed is a very important factor to
consider when you're deploying
fungicides against this pathogen it has
a very high potential to develop
resistance when this resistance
inevitably occurs in some of these fungi
fungicides there may be very little in
the research pipeline that will replace
the fungicides that we have today that
should especially concern us as we move
towards production in systems such as
high tunnels where pottery mildews can
develop much more explosively than they
do in open fields so I've taken as the
inspiration for this talk one of my
favorite authors Mark Twain who observed
that it ain't what we don't know that's
the problem it's what we do know that
ain't so and I've used that as the the
organizational organizational structure
of the talk we'll start with what we
thought we knew that is not necessarily
so and then we'll move on to what we
didn't know until quite recently so
let's get started on that it would be
reasonable to assume
this pathogen like many powdery mildews
infects the meristematic tissues deep
within the crown of the plant and
survives winter there it's easy enough
to find this assumption stated as a fact
in in many sources on this disease the
trouble is that when you try to find
conclusive experimental proof for this
as a form of overwintering or in any of
the previous research it's just not
there in fact when we stripped dorman
crowns of the mildew infected leaves and
then first them to regrow in confinement
they remained mildew free and
significantly when we did not remove
those senescent but persistent leaves a
small but very important percentage of
the plants developed mildew on the new
leaves as they emerged so the source of
infection seems to be those persistent
leaves not over wintering in the Crown's
so we can't prove that the fungus never
survives in the crown it's very
difficult to prove a negative only that
we can't detect it and neither it has
anyone else to our knowledge however
these senescent persistent leaves appear
to be quite suitable for carrying the
pathogen through winter often very well
protected under layers of mulch or
fleece and in places with with real
winter snow and I'm going to return to
those persistent leaves in a minute but
I want to first move on to the next
thing that we thought we knew what
recently had to rethink and that's the
role of these small spherical spore
containing structures here which you can
see as I move the cursor around of those
structures form late in the season and
they're called Kleist aficio they form
in the mildew colony these are close to
thisi of forming on the underside of a
severely mildewed leaf because no one
had ever succeeded in infecting
strawberry plants with the spores
contained in these Kleist officia they
were routinely dismissed as a major
source of infection over the last three
years
we've learned much more about these as
sources of primary infection we've
learned that like many powdery mildew
strawberry powdery mildew is composed of
two mating types essentially male and
female types that means that the
populations are essentially divided both
of those have to be present and then
they have to be paired on the same leaf
before those close to physio will form a
consequently formation of closed officia
is is affected by disease severity and
by time there has to be enough disease
and for a long enough period that the
compatible mating types become paired on
that same leaf essentially they have to
find each other once they do the Kleist
oficio are initiated and thereafter they
take about four weeks before they look
mature however they need a much longer
period before they become
physiologically mature and are able to
release those infectious spores in the
field that maturation process is delayed
by the arrival of winter temperatures
but in spring when the strawberry plants
resume development so do the Kleist
oficio I'll have more to say in a minute
about which leaves are susceptible but
when susceptible leaves are inoculated
with spores from overwintered close to
fisa it's really not difficult to
reproduce this disease so they are a
functional and often very abundant
source of primary infection I had
mentioned leaf susceptibility there are
a number of reports in the literature
noting that powdery mildew of strawberry
is found primarily on the lower surface
of older leaves and therefore the lower
surface must be more susceptible or the
pathogen is very sensitive to solar
radiation now those are reasonable
speculations because they're easily
supported by observations in the field
the disease is indeed more common in
commercial plantings on the lower
surface of older leaves but in fact when
we conducted controlled of enough
okya lations of strawberry leaves at
different stages of development we found
that first only the very youngest leaves
were highly susceptible secondly there's
no difference in the susceptibility of
the upper or lower surface of those
leaves and lastly the upper leaf surface
escapes infection during the susceptible
stage because it's obscured by badly
folding you can see how highly folded
these very young and very susceptible
leaves are by the time that upper
surface is exposed the leaf has
essentially developed age-related or
what we call antigenic resistance to
powdery mildew and that resistance that
that natural resistance of the older
leaves is quite suppressed suppressive
towards new infections so the end result
is that the disease is often confined to
the lower leaf surface until quite late
in the season but the distribution of
the disease on the lower leaf surface of
older leaves has more to do with the
opportunity to infect a particular leaf
surface during that narrow window of
susceptibility than it has to do with
any other factor
now I said I would return to the subject
of the senescent but persistent green
leaves that often survive winter
strawberries not a typical deciduous
perennial plant that sheds its leaves in
awe in poverty millions of many if not
most deciduous perennial plants the
cluster theseus are readily dispersed by
rain from colonies on the leaves and
then they tend to attach to the bark of
those perennial plants where they
survive winter but the cluster these--
on strawberry leaves are very tightly
bound to the mildew colony and they're
very resistant to removal in fact
they're quite well embedded in a sort of
a rat's nest of these hyphy these
thread-like structures of the fungus and
that keeps them very well attached to
the leaf they've they've obviously
learned over several millions of years
that these leaves aren't going anywhere
and and so why should they
the Kleist avicii are one source of
primary inoculum and the colony's
overwintering on the senescent leaves
are the only other source what would
happen if we eliminated both and we've
just completed the the third year of
field trials in both New York and Norway
to try to answer that question without
getting into too much detail we
essentially established pathogen-free
plantings from either seedlings or from
tissue culture plants and then we left
them unsprayed for powdery mildew now
even though these were within 200 yards
of severely diseased plantings and
they're located in air in areas where
both commercial strawberry production is
present and there are numerous wild
strawberry plants those plantings
established from all clean plants they
started clean and they developed only
traces of powdery mildew during year one
even though they were never sprayed with
fungicides and these were highly
susceptible varieties while nothing
lasts forever when the plants were left
untreated for two years of the disease
eventually increased to severe levels on
the foliage and occasionally on the
fruit but the experiments clearly showed
that the benefit is there from starting
with mildew free plants the level of
disease was influenced far more by the
resident of pathogen population then by
contamination from outside sources so
what are the applications of this new
biological and epidemiological
information on pathogen on the pathogen
first there are substantial benefits to
be gained from starting with mildew free
plants and taking steps to keep them in
that condition for as long as possible
by doing so you may first avoid
contaminating the planting by
introducing the pathogen on senescent
leaves that's one source of inoculum you
can greatly reduce or even eliminate
secondly you can prevent the formation
of kleist aficio perhaps indefinitely as
their formation requires severe and
protracted disease because the pathogen
population is composed of two mating
type
so unless the disease gets severe or
persists for a very long period of time
those Christ if these here will not form
that's the only other source of primary
inoculum thirdly you'll improve the
performance and increase the longevity
of the fungicides that are applied and
reduce the risk of fungicide resistance
that's going to become increasingly
important as the number of available
fungicides dwindles and the remaining
options are inherently of perhaps less
active against this pathogen now
additionally the rapid development of
antigenic or age-related resistance in
strawberry leaves means that it's the
very youngest foliage that has to be the
target of the fungicides directed
against powdery mildew if you
effectively protect those disease they
very soon become resistant and will no
longer require your assistance if you
fail to do so there's very little that
you can do to eradicate the established
and very well protected colonies on the
lower surface deep within the plant
canopy and so I'll leave you with these
words of wisdom start clean and keep it
clean I'll thank you for your attention
and I'll be happy to answer any
questions and in whatever time remains
and I haven't touched on varietal
resistance but we can deal with that in
the question period thank you alright
thank you so much David
I see a couple of people typing so
perhaps we're going to get questions dr.
Mike Allyson dr. David Kaduri are still
here for some questions so please take
the opportunity we have a little bit
extra time and
they were two terrific presentations i
do want to while people are typing i do
want to say that some of you may have
had some
audio and I am not sure why that happens
I think it has something to do with
bandwidth and depending upon the usage
perhaps here at a major institution and
there's a lot of usage that may affect
why you're not getting consistent audio
and I think it's different for every
location a one thing that I can say is
that we did find that people who are on
a wireless connection that does seem to
result in a more broken audio
that that's something that you might
Molly shawn has a question here it says
do dormant plants from the nursery tend
to come with powdery mildew on the few
cleaning leaves and how do you make sure
you start a planting without powdery
mildew
are there any of owners of strawberry
nurseries on the line here before before
I get into trouble okay there's no way
of knowing without a microscopic
inspection of the plants whether or not
they carry powdery mildew it's very
likely though that they do although the
nurseries tend to intensively spray
those plants not so much in the United
States but in Europe the nursery plants
that are heavily sprayed are thought to
be one of the primary means by which
fungicide resistance strains are
introduced and that becomes a particular
problem in the high tunnel production
which is much more common in Europe here
I I couldn't say certainly if you're
getting tissue culture plants or plants
grown from seed there's much less of a
possibility or likelihood that they're
coming in with powdery mildew otherwise
I think you you just take your chances
all right great we have a couple of
other people that are typing
and
I'm going to move I'm going to move us
into the final setting so that people
can download the handouts while we are
talking
I don't know if you folks so I think
this is for David Marvin prince has a
question about managing powdery mildew
and
all the things that I mentioned
regarding the management of powdery
mildew in infield plantings become much
more important in high tunnel production
certainly if you had the option of
growing a variety with good base level
of powdery mildew resistance that
becomes almost critical in high tunnel
production if you're receiving dormant
crowns and you suspect that there may be
pottery will do mycelium Harvard on
those persistent green leaves you may
want to consider actually stripping
those before the planting is started
thereafter you want to be especially
diligent with the application of
fungicides in particular as those new
leaves emerge and to keep that epidemic
under almost continual suppression in
particular if you're growing a highly
mildew susceptible variety all right
great there's also a question about
wild strawberry as a source of a napkin
uh it's it's minimally important for
powdery mildew and then chautauqua
county has a question about recommending
what do you recommend for application
equipment to use for the application of
fungicides and maybe this is actually
for both dr. Ellis and dr.
well that might go first
like do you wanna very okay hear me yes
beautifully um you know when you get
into application equipment that's kind
of a science onto itself and ever since
I started working with strawberries this
question comes up you've got range from
people putting materials on through the
irrigation system through all kinds of
different sprayers and what I tell
people is number one I don't know what
the best system is but the most
important thing is you've got to have a
system that's going to give you a
complete coverage of what you're trying
to spray and I can't get any better than
that I'd say only that the the the
timing of those fungicides and the
choice of the materials in conjunction
with all the other things you should be
doing to manage powdery mildew are
probably more important than the
particular piece of equipment assuming
the equipment is suitable for spraying
strawberries in the first place I am I
mean that's that's well said there's no
doubt about that one thing that's just
kind of a an observation if you will if
you are in a program where you are going
to be spraying you know you're going to
be spraying a lot i think the layout of
the field has is is very important i
think it's important to have some grass
strips that you can actually run the
tractor on and have a sprayer that's
going to deliver out about 10 rows to
keep you out of that planning most of
the growers that I know up here or in
Ohio or doing that and it really makes
life an awful lot easier
that is excellent if I want to draw
people's attentions to theirs to the
fungicides for strawberry fruit rots
that is a
hand out that dr. Mike Ellis developed
and you can upload that onto your own
computer it's very comprehensive and
then there's a powdery mildew fact sheet
that you might also want to have I will
add the PowerPoint publication from dr.
doback edori to this so you can access
it later but I'm just having some
problems
doing that right now but that will be
available on the recorded version and I
just
let people know they have a few more
minutes before we even reach two o'clock
if anybody has any other questions but
yes Laura if you could make my
powerpoint available i'll appreciate it
too certainly and when we get when we
get into questions I'd like to address
that one about plastic culture versus
matter grill in terms of the fruit rot I
think we're right there so you can go
ahead and talk about that okay first of
all you know the difference between
matted row could the control of fruit
rots in matted row and and the plastic
culture our annual productions is just a
world apart and the point well made that
in the annual production you've got this
constant flush or Flushing's of flowers
that need to be protected for botrytis
control at any rate in perennial matted
row I think it's a pretty simple system
at least in Ohio we do very very few
sprays prior to the initiation of bloom
we target sprays during bloom and this
is fairly easy to do you've got to do it
for each variety but you've usually got
about a two week no more than three that
you target sprays for botrytis control
and then to growers kind of play it by
ear if it's a normal year and it's not
hot and it's not extremely wet you may
not need very many more sprays but a hot
years you might have to think about some
anthracnose sprays or if you saw
anthracnose the year before at any rate
I think you've got a lot more options
and you can you can look at the weather
more you can you have more I p.m. type
things that you can consider in
perennial matted row in plastic culture
I don't think you have the leeway for
that the investment that you have just
the nature the it seems like the
introduction of anthracnose on tips and
on plants is very very common and at
least if I had my investment in a
plastic culture planning
would maintain a pretty strict straw
fungicide program starting early in the
season with just straight captain to
keep populations of anthracnose down
when bloom came I'd have a program
that's going to control all the major
fruit rots and we and if you look at the
the options you can put together a
program that will take you right up
through harvest it's pretty intensive
but if you let something like
anthracnose get loose on you in those
planning zits yeah you just can't get
back on top of all right that's a great
point it looks like there's a question
Kathy heidenreich said asks with straw
over
well this is I didn't quite finish my
talk here this afternoon but at any rate
I would did want to mention cultural
practices straw is extremely beneficial
in a planning for preventing fruit rots
almost all or all of the diseases are
spread pretty well with splash dispersal
and straw between the rows especially in
perennial matted rose I've never want to
see soil never what barriers in contact
with soil leather rots just going to be
a major problem at any rate a good layer
of straw most we've shown that even on
fairly poorly drained sites a good solid
layer of mulch will give you a very very
good control of leather rot it protects
the fruit from contact with the soil
even if you get puddling on top to soil
the rain that are the straw breaks up
the raindrops and it prevents it from
splash and it has a very profound effect
on splash dispersal I think even in
plastic culture if you can afford it
there ought to be something between
those rolls rather than just bare soil I
think it's more important in the in the
proteome matted row but you know a lot
of our growers will put a layer of straw
down in between the rows and in their
plastic culture as well it's it really
goes a long way thank you and then Alan
has a questions about what
are not in sex play a role in the spread
of fruit rods I think insects are their
own problem when I think about
controlling these fruit rots and the
development of these fruit rots insects
to me are not a major factor in their
spread if they are I'm just not aware of
it they're kind of their own problem
that have to be taken care of within the
overall management there is another
question probably for both of you
Chautauqua County asks if there's an
advantage to applying a fungicide now
before you put the straw down
I'd like to go first on that when a lot
of the real good work on botrytis was
done there was a really some tremendous
work done a lot of it by Sutton up in
Guelph Wilcox and in prints and in New
York we did some in Ohio but there were
a lot of things looked at and one of
them was an application of fungicide in
the fall I think it's a waste of money I
would not recommend it if you want to
try it do it certainly not against the
law but I think it's a waste of money I
think you're still going to have plenty
of inoculum there to start out in the
spring and I think I'd put my emphasis
on on targeting a program but protecting
the the blooms we did do some work here
in Ohio and I could never find any
benefits from it I'd agree with that
Mike 44 powdery mildew in particular the
cluster the-- seein is has evolved to to
withstand a very harsh environment and
it's very resistant to penetration by
fungicides that are applied in fall so
you're much better off reducing the
amount of disease and that alone will
prevent the formation of the
overwintering structure then you would
be in trying to eradicate it once it's
formed so by the time for all rolls
around it's really too late to do much
about powdery mildew for the following
year and in terms of applying a
fungicide to get at the overwintering
stage
it is a good question and it's been
looked at but like i said i don't
recommend I I have to admit I did not
have time and I apologize to put any
final polling questions to you folks but
I I do hope that you enjoyed these talks
I thought they were absolutely wonderful
and it's great to be able to have access
to nationally known experts on these
topics so it's really nice without
having to drive to ohio and so it's
great to have both dr. david Kaduri and
dr. Mike Ellis and I want to thank you
agris more I'd like to make one more
comment before we break up Dave Dave
didn't mention anything about varietals
susceptibility but for me one of the
major things that I try to push in my
extension programs mainly for leaf spots
and powdery mildew I'm not an expert on
powdery mildew but you know we have some
very good resistance and especially when
I first started working with
strawberries the varieties coming out of
our USDA program and in Jeanne galletta
they had really had excellent and still
do have excellent resistance to the leaf
spots and a lot of varieties you just
don't have to spray for powdery mildew
and then all of a sudden we'll start
getting some introduced and they're just
indicators for powdery mildew and the
leaf spot and I try to tell our growers
well you've really better check these
varieties out and if you're dealing with
in a case of extreme susceptibility you
ought to try to avoid it or you'll go
and be spraying and I still think we
have some excellent resistance in a lot
of different varieties that people could
take advantage of and it's especially
true resistance when we talk about the
the root rot diseases
we really need to emphasize the use of
resistance whenever we can get it I
would go along with that Mike especially
the as you move towards high tunnel
production powdery mildew is is not
routinely destructive under field
conditions it is routinely destructive
in high tunnels in particular when
you're growing a mildew susceptible
variety and so very often we develop
these attachments to certain varieties
because they have just well they have
wonderful taste good horticultural
properties and infield plantings we can
manage powdery mildew with fungicides
it's a very different world as as you
quickly find out when you move into high
tunnel production and the resistant
varieties there it just makes a lot of
sense to start with that as the as the
base of the disease management alright
that those are wonderful points and
there is a question about powdery mildew
resistant varieties in the hour in our
particular guidelines we don't have any
listed we'd have some that are
definitely susceptible and that those
would be listed in the guidelines but
maybe maybe Mike or David you have some
that you know are actually resistant to
powdery mildew that you could
I I don't have them memorized but in all
of our literature and I know I'm the
mid-atlantic berry guide and in our
literature there's tables that have the
relative susceptibility for almost you
know most of the currently used
varieties and I think the informations
fairly reliable I a few kind of stick
out in mind that are extremely
susceptible this a dar select is one
that is is really it indicator for
pottery bill do but that's another
reason I like to emphasize you know
having these resources this information
having it and in referring to it but I'm
sure that you all have some information
on relative susceptibility of the
varieties to leave spots and powdery
mildew I would check the extension
resources online or the published
reserves to see not only what is
resistant to powdery mildew but what has
some pretty broad-based resistance to
some of the other diseases as well you
don't want to have a resistant variety
too powdery mildew and then you know
take comfort in that as it as it Ross oh
yeah you know one thing I was up talking
to the growers in Nova Scotia several
years ago and I didn't realize you know
loose scorch it just never seems like a
serious disease to me never saw it much
it's because we have excellent
resistance I guess up there it's just a
horrible disease and if you don't have
leaf scorch resistance you don't you
don't raise strawberries up there so
well thank you guys very much I will try
to get my hands on a table and also post
that in the
file shares so that people can access
that quickly for both some of the other
diseases leaf leaf spots as well as
fruit rots and certainly powdery mildew
will try to make sure that that is
available to all of you again I want to
thank the speakers I want to thank all
of you that have joined this webinar I
want to draw your attention to the fact
that the next webinar is the only one of
this series that will be on a friday
it's Friday October thirtieth at one
o'clock in the afternoon again all of
you that are registered will receive the
connection information for that and that
will be on weed control in strawberries
dr. Marvin pritts and dr. Robin
bellandur will be talking about cultural
and chemical control options and i also
want to urge those of you who have
enjoyed these two please let other
people know especially growers who might
be somewhat reluctant to try this
particular form of program delivery we
think it's very accessible and I think
they're going to be pleased with how
easy it is and the quality of the
lectures so please talk to your
colleagues and other growers and farmers
we'd love to have more
we have room for about a hundred people
to to join in on one lecture as a live
lecture so I just want to urge you we're
going to do a little PR blast so you'll
hear more about us in the near future
and thank you again for attending
you
you
you
you